Quite rightfully, everybody's been talking about their first image of a black hole, which we've ever taken absolutely amazing
But I've been wondering where actually is it so here it is
If you look into the sky between the Virgo and Leo
Constellations just around here
It's just above the horizon in spring in the northern hemisphere and in autumn and winter in the southern hemisphere
Here is a load of real astronomical photos stitched together of the sky. We'll zoom into the black hole
It's 50 3.5 million light years away in the Virgo cluster
So this image is obviously a tiny section of sky but in real terms is absolutely huge
Here's what the solar system would look like if we put it inside it the mass of this black hole is a colossal
6.5 billion times the mass of the Sun and
Despite the blurry image is actually at a crazy resolution two thousand times higher resolution than the Hubble Space Telescope
Capturing this image was only possible because we made a network of radio dishes
That added up to a virtual telescope the size of the entire Earth
so the engineering achievement to get this image is absolutely insane and a
Amazing achievement which is why everyone's so excited about this
And the dark patch in this image is the first time where we've seen light being annihilated from the universe
Which is so cool
actually, we we don't really know what happens to the light when it falls into a black hole because we don't have a theory of
Quantum gravity, but for practical purposes, it's gone forever from this mega zoom that we did
You don't really get a sense of the geometry of what's going on
So here's another way to picture where the m87 supermassive black hole is
If you look just above the ecliptic plane from Earth out of our solar system
Past our closest stars
Out of the Milky Way
Past the Local Group of galaxies it's over here in the Virgo cluster. I
Love these images so just for fun bigger than this is the local supercluster and bigger than that is the observable universe
And that's everything apart from the infinite universe beyond the observable universe
Space it's so big